une semaine après on ne voit presque
plus le parvis du collège du bois
d'aulne à conflans sainte honorine
une semaine après les fleurs bougies
dessins en tout genre continuent
d'affluer
une semaine après les hommages
continuent pour samuel pâtit ce
professeur d'histoire géographie
décapité vendredi 16 octobre par un
terroriste pour avoir montré des
caricatures en classe à ses élèves
samedi parmi les nombreuses personnes
venues se recueillir sur place cette
enseignante francilienne interrogé par
astrid bergère les propos sélectionnés
par eléonore si nos pieds je n'ai pas
participé aux marches ou du fer entre
marche et je trouvais ça important de de
vue venir là pour lui rendre hommage et
ça que c'est impressionnant parce que je
pensais pas qu'il y avait une ambiance
une telle ambiance quoi on sent le
recueillement ont sans l'incompréhension
et voilà c'est quand même malheureux
d'en arriver là la liberté d'expression
c'est au programme donc il ya aucun
aucune raison quoi on se doit de
l'enseigné et voilà quoi ça fait partie
d'un programme comme le reste